dog people at resorts get it's like
boo-boo-boo burnt oh my god dude lobster
read so many people get cancer that was
one of the things there was a group of
four people yeah when I said that's that
there was someone out there at 6 a.m.
every day Morrie lying by the pool yeah
it was a script before people one of
them that one a woman one of the woman
one of the one woman one of the women
she looked her skin tone she white yeah
her skin tone looked like she jumped in
like a pool full of chocolate yeah and
got out dark chocolate - not even milk
chocolate our chocolate
she was [ __ ] bronzed you know she
straight-up looked like she was another
race
that's crazy sick she looked like she
was Indian or something that's crazy
it was in an insane hurry it looked like
you could skin her and make a purse out
of it out of her skin I saw a girl like
that in Venice like a year ago I mean
boy Eric we're walking out on the Venice
pier and this girl walks up and I'm like
yo son she got to go to the [ __ ]
chemo
yeah whatever like right now like she
has to go to the chemo lab you got a
chemo job you gotta get chemo right now
I think she could have walked up to a
doctor and he could have been like
you're here for it I am said if you want
to just skip right past our moles like
let's just get these things off right
now boys get any worse it just eyeballs
hurt yeah you got about I don't know six
months Oh feel free to head to to keep
the chemo spot my chemo guy he's good
name's Eric did great chemo yeah he does
a great team love job I got a great
chemo guy is that the [ __ ] out of you
this awesome clothes
[Music]
is that Dustin phone these are custom
pump these are Gustin phone mr. Duffy
all in my bag on my wrists